he is an 11-time all-star and two-time
nba champion olympic gold medalist and
now
to that stellar resume you can add
basketball hall of fame inductee
for the 2021 class he's also an author
letters to a young athlete is available
today wherever books are sold he is
chris
bosh how are you sir i'm good how are
you i'm doing better for talking to you
congrats on your book
uh thank you very much man i really do
appreciate that we're very excited about
it
so letters to a young athlete this is
about what
are you are you writing letters to
yourself is that what this book is about
chris what do you got for me here that
that's fascinating um a lot of people uh
asked that about the uh
letters to the younger self my younger
self in particular
i'm speaking um you know not only to
young athletes but
to anyone trying um you know to aspire
to do something great
um i know how i feel
how lucky i am how grateful i am to have
the career that i had
and you know even though it came to an
abrupt end
i still appreciated it and i still
learned so many lessons from it so
you know um in that success i wanted to
find
those things that other people could
really really find
helpful and find that would be
beneficial to their life
and you know they could take it and use
it for themselves what is that what are
you finding what did you find that you
think uh you needed to impart
to the youth of today as they try to
become you
to be honest well i mean you know the
the different um obstacles
uh that they will face the the fact that
they will face obstacles um
the fact that you have to think deeply
about what you want to do
i i talk about that and uh chapter
called finding your why
you know it it's um it's just like a lot
of lessons i feel that
really really helped me out and those
are the things that i wish i would have
known
coming up um during my time so
you know if if they can take something
from my story and you know to be frank
most of the lessons the best lessons i
learned were from other people's
mistakes or lessons you know and
and i really i really wanted to bring
something like that
uh to where younger athletes or old
athletes or
really anyone you know could uh really
take heat from
so what what uh interesting use heat i
like that
um so what what uh
what did you learn for whose mistake
gave you the biggest
um you know epiphany in your career
chris bosh um
i i don't know if i would chalk it up to
a mistake i would say i had uh i had a
conversation with multiple guys
um when i was in toronto just trying to
figure out what
it is i had a very tough decision to
make and i didn't know what to do and
and you know bill walton was like bill
walton was one of the guys that i spoke
to just
you know i asked him like what what what
is it all about
what what is this the nba experience
what should i go for what should i be
thinking about he said you want to play
on the big stage and that's all he told
me but
you know i pretty much knew that he
meant going for a championship
and you know you've got to do it now so
i'm glad that i was able
to really take that advice and listen to
it i mean it's not
you know i wouldn't necessarily say um
it's from another person's mistake
so that was more so i guess in life you
know
not so much in basketball and and you
definitely shorthanded what bill walton
told you he didn't say it just to you in
one succinct sentence
i imagine chris i mean he he he probably
went on and on and on about it but oh
yeah you boiled it down
you know he can go yeah i mean
all the people to ask about life he's
definitely wanted to do that i've got
yes christmas bosh here on the rich
eisen show pat riley wrote the forward
of your book what did
what did he tell you when you were
knocking on doors or
he knocked on yours and that's how you
wound up with the heat eventually
creating a
a super team with lebron and and dwyane
wade that we see have been replicated
many times since then yeah what about
that
he you know pat pretty much what pat did
he
he understood um that you need
great teams to win now they call them
super teams
you know in my opinion you could argue
that there
has always been a super team to win an
nba championship
very seldomly because they're not you
know
um and you know just at that point in
time
he you know he dumped a bunch of when we
were in the meeting
he rolled up his sleeves took his jacket
off rolled up his sleeves
and just dumped a bunch of 2006
championship rings
on the table and then you know
he has me pick one up and then he then
he goes into his
his thing and he's a you know an
eloquent dynamic speaker yes
and afterwards he told me to keep one of
the rings and
and give it back to him after i win my
first one
and you know that's a hell of a pitch
right there
so did you keep the ring did you
actually do it did you actually walk out
yeah i kept it i actually still have it
i haven't given it back to him
um i don't even know if i've told him
yet that i still have it but i gotta i
gotta let him know like yo you wanna you
know
i still have it so yeah he didn't like
give you a receipt or anything like that
i mean he just let you
say you keep it i hadn't committed to
signing or anything
you know but you know pat is just
man pat riley you know and uh that was
very riley asking
i mean it put things into perspective
for me and it was
the chance of a lifetime to go after uh
winning a championship or at least
try you know and and that was the
decision i made
i'm so fascinated by this so one last
follow-up
how many rings did he spill out like out
of a box like literally spill it out on
the table and
and it just made noises on the table and
you picked one out
literally yeah it was like um it was
like a uh
like a um little bag um
yeah you know this is the only analogy i
could think of but you've seen a crown
royal bag right yes of course
not to say it wasn't a crown royal bag
but
right nice you felt bad sure yeah right
and it was like a black black fell back
and yeah he
dumped him out i don't remember how many
there were but there were a few
and um yeah you just say yeah take that
one
chris bosh here on the richard eisen
show
so chris um you're seeing lebron now do
it
at such um i guess what will you say
years later
i don't even want to call it an advanced
stage because ages
is a number but it does look like again
um that that at this point in time uh
anthony davis is
hurt uh the lakers have uh an
interesting challenge now
in front of them tonight against chris
paul which is fascinating you know that
they have a relationship
outside of the court as well what are
your thoughts on lebron continuing to do
it right now and his chance to
maybe put this team on his back and
continue on as a seventh seed
what are your thoughts on i mean it's
insane just the fact that he's able
um you know it's it's really you know
all that work that he put into uh his
body throughout his whole career all the
training
uh that you do or for moments like this
this and especially early on in your
career
it's in hopes that you can perform at a
high level uh consistently
at the age that he's at but i mean i
think
he's the type of athlete that's trying
to break
new ground and you know that's what he's
doing and i mean
even michael jordan you know he
consistently played at a high level
until 36 and then came back and played
at 40. you know so
it's out there and you know brian being
the fitness freak that he is
i know that's definitely a challenge and
i mean you know he's out to
be one of if not the best player of all
time
and that's his goal and and i know you
know he i know how much he puts into the
game and how hard he works
so i think as long as he you know this
year was a pretty serious injury
that he'll have to take care of and i
mean he will have to expend a lot of
energy
um uh tonight in that particular game
and it will be difficult but
you know like i say breaking new ground
is not easy and
and of course that's how the basketball
guys put it you know you like okay yeah
you're man in the best shape of your
life at 37 years old okay your
number two is out and caldwell pope is
out and all right you still got to win
put the team on your back again
[Laughter]
so we'll see what happens we'll see how
you respond so i mean you could sit
there
you could make a case chris because you
had a front row seat for this that
and i did too um sitting on sportscenter
doing highlights of his high school game
you know and and so that's how far back
he goes and
i haven't been in espn in 18 years and
and he is maybe the first superstar
athlete in the nba
to have his entire career take place in
the 24 7 365
sports cable television world and sports
talk world
and social media world where everything
is out there
so is there one thing about lebron that
we don't know
that you would be able to fill us in on
at all
chris um if in my book i talk about how
much he put into the game and how hard
he works i mean
you know he makes he makes things look
easy and he's not the one to boast and
brag
on what how much he works on the game
and how much he puts into the game
so like it's always really funny to you
know to
of course you get criticized right it's
a part of the game uh but just hear the
critical narratives on what he can and
can't do and
and all of these things which you know
it's interesting when they're like oh
he's aging and is he i think one year
was like oh is he washed and
yes you know just i just wanted to give
more perspective on
how much he put into his body over his
career and how
focused and dedicated you know he is to
the craft you know he's very smart
individually
highly intelligent but most of all he
loves what he does and
you know he's one of the best teammates
um that i've had he loves basketball
loves having a good time he loves
getting the fellas together and
and going after a goal what's your best
guess on how much longer he wants to do
it the
the concept in the media when we when
whenever we
we get to that point is that he might
want to stick around for his son
to be drafted in the nba and kind of
play and play with him
kind of like the griffeys did if you
will yeah and baseball do you think that
that's
that's his the way he's viewing his
endgame basketball
scenario um that's a great question i'm
not sure i'm not sure but no one knowing
brian he'll have something up his sleeve
you know what i mean who knows i know um
i know he probably still wants to play
at the level he's playing at
you know for another year if not two um
uh i know that for sure but you know as
brownie
continues to develop i know they'll keep
their eye on that situation
i know he'll continue to keep his
options open but
you know as an athlete i know how it you
know it is i mean he's
if he gets to where it's like yo i've
done everything and
that's before his son starts playing and
he and he has nothing else
to give to the game he might wake up and
feel that one day you know we we never
know if he's blessed to be able to get
to that point but
you know i think um i think we'll have
to wait and see man that would be pretty
cool like the griffy's not just on the
same team and
you know get back-to-back buckets like
cool stuff like that it'd be great
chris bosh few more minutes left with
the hall of fame inductee
and the author letters to a young
athlete is available today where all
books are sold
uh not to turn you into the paparazzi
but i'll do it anyway the the
conversation today is
kyrie stomping on a logo um and
i think it's a and and that that was out
of bounds if you will
and you know i i don't want to get
anywhere remotely close to the false
equivalency of of a bottle being thrown
at him and that that that one thing
leads to another i think those are two
separate issues but what what do you
think about him stomping on a logo
is that disrespectful is that something
that does
merit um anger towards kyrie
chris well i mean yeah you know look
we've played plenty of games
um we've had rivalries i mean i've
played in plenty of rivalries i've
played
at the td garden you know usually when
you win that game you want to get out of
there
to be to be frank with you um yeah i
mean look
you know you don't want ever you don't
want ever as an athlete you don't want
things to be misinterpreted um so yeah
you know if
if whether it was misinterpreted or not
if he goes and stomps on the thing and
that will revoke a reaction and people
will um you know react a certain way and
you know that's why i always encourage
guys after the game is over you know
shake hands and get on out of there
that way nothing else no any
extracurricular things can happen
and yeah i mean you know how it is man i
mean
you know you win a game and you've done
your job you know
and that's you know that's that was the
best thing probably for everybody to do
it's unfortunate everything that's
happened you know with the whole bottle
throwing and you know things getting out
of pocket but you know
criticism and unruly fans sometimes
that's a part of the game
you know we just have to be able to to
take it
and um and move on and hopefully not put
us put ourselves in a situation where
you know people are kind of asking
questions like well what does that mean
because the narrative will continue
to go so what advice would you give
kyrie
and also harden and durant durant's been
down this road before with the warriors
yeah um but uh the the pressure that
comes with having
the concept of a super team stamped on
you
as you they go about your business i
mean i'm kind of going through
from the other angle everybody's saying
well you know what we can't stand this
team because they're
kind of rigging the system to put all
these stars together
and you've lived it so what advice would
you give these three
gents as they go about their business
tonight and beyond with everybody
expecting them to win it all
what do you got for me i mean you know
play ball and you know we play this ball
we play this game to have fun
um with the heat that's what we
eventually had to get to
and you know of course it's a different
market in a different time and
you know they're the the power the
amount of
talent in the time that they put it in
of course you know it's like a
is this a quick flame very combustible
right and
and you know with that a lot of people
start giving their opinions and you're
on the mountaintop before you're
you know you've even done anything and
you know it's just something you have to
deal with
i would i would you know have those guys
get back to enjoying
you know if they're not enjoying it get
back to enjoy because you want to have
fun
you know i think um just in sports
overall
it just seems like it seems a little
tense right now which everybody is kind
of
you know have some pent up aggression
because of you know the times we're
trying to rebound from
but you know let's get back to having
fun let's appreciate everything let's
not be disrespectful
you know fans hey if you're coming to
the game cheer for your team you could
boo the other team but let's
let's keep it let you know let's keep it
cool and have a good time and get back
to
to doing what the sport is intended to
do which is bring people together
to have a good time and and and to root
for their teams
so uh before i let you go chris bosh if
i had written a letter
to uh that uh national honor society
student
at uh let me get this right lincoln high
school in dallas saying you're going to
be a hall of famer one day if i'd
written that note and
passed it to you in class or something
like that what would what would young
chris bosh have said
if that note said you're going to be
you're going to be in the basketball
hall of fame
um as an eleven-time all-star two-time
nba champion olympic gold medalist
what would that what would you have done
with that letter chris i probably
okay i would have kept it i couldn't say
that i would have framed it but i would
have kept it and
i probably would have went right back
right to the gym because
if someone believes in me you know
whether they're prophesied something or
not
if i need if i'm gonna if i know this is
my future
and i wanted to make it come true i need
to get better
and i know for sure that i will be right
back there in the gym
getting more shots up trying to figure
more about the game
and then you know obviously go about
your business in the classroom as well
because you never know when it's going
to get taken away from you and i know
that's part of your book too right
as you learn in a doctor's office that
it's all over
it's oh yeah have have those other
interests no other things that you like
just don't be
you know one-dimensional that you know
you don't have any have that thing you
go after but
um you know there's greatness in hobbies
and and you know
it's good to have other interests
because you might have to use them in
more ways than you know
so are you going to have riley when
you're up there uh
roll just championship rings out during
your speech or something like that
let's get some flair to your speech here
yeah yeah that'll be some nice player
right there
are you starting to work on it are you
starting that already oh yeah i'm in the
lab yeah we're
um i have uh i have um some guys i write
speeches with and
yeah we're uh we're we're we've got a
like a
stack full of papers man and we're going
through we're listening to speeches
we're um we're we're very excited about
it we're
we're going to make it happen how about
this chris cause i always
like leaving my guests in a better spot
in which i found them despite how
terrific they are
in a spot like you how about you tell
the story
you told me earlier about pat recruiting
you
telling you to pick out a ring from 2006
and swap it out and you never gave it
back how about you give it back to him
during your speech
how about that that'll be a good one
though there you go yeah that's pretty
good man
take it out of your pocket and say here
it is pat give it back
that's a good one i like that man i like
that how about that and just you don't
think no credit just take it chris
there's an iron rich and eisen but i'm a
team player don't worry
hey man right now hey i appreciate that
pass man i might use that
that's a good one give it back to him
during your speech
saying thanks thanks for the ring pat
appreciate it and the other ones too
there you go okay thanks for the call
chris let's uh
look for my call uh more often i'd love
to just catch up with you and get your
thoughts on what's going on in the
in the nba and more and uh also congrats
on the book
absolutely thanks a lot man you bet it
letters to a young athlete available
today wherever books are sold chris bosh
right here on the rich eisen show hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that
watch more right here